[موسيقى]
لدينا بلورات m8000 مجمعة معًا
كعدسة واحدة موحدة ، تختلف ألوان كل
بلورة
قليلاً تقريبًا ، لكننا مقارنة بلوحة Rothko ،
فنحن نستخدم
نفس اللون بشكل أساسي ولكن قيم لونية مختلفة
، وهذه هي الطريقة التي نقوم بها  نحصل على
عمق هذه العدسة ، تلك الروافد الفولاذية هي
رمزية جدًا لبناء
مبنى هذه المدينة العظيمة الجديدة التي لا
تزال مستمرة ، وأنا على النقيض من ذلك
وبين النفيسة والقطع التي لا تشوبها
شائبة ووضوح كريستال سواروفسكي
وهذا  إن المقارنة المثيرة للاهتمام
مع مدينة دبي نفسها
قوية جسديًا
ضمن اختبار جميل
[موسيقى]
النحت العام الجيد هو كل شيء عن
إشراك الجمهور وهذه هي الرسالة
وراء المقدمة وهذا بالضبط
ما تفعله إذا نظرت وراء هذا الآن
هناك أشخاص يأخذون
صور القطعة وأيضًا مع
القطعة وهي تشارك عاطفيًا جدًا
بهذه الطريقة ، ولا نحاول أن نقول
للناس إنها هذه هي S  الأمم المتحدة هي
دائرة رمز بدايات جديدة
ما تقرأه فيها